la vía correcta para evitar que vuelva a
postularse sería el impeachment el
impeachment que aunque solamente quedan
diez días de su mandato el impidió y
podía comenzar y proceder
aún después de que ya termine su término
la herramienta 25 por otra parte es una
enmienda que nunca se ha utilizado para
destituir a un presidente existe en la
constitución hasta ahora solamente se ha
utilizado cuando un presidente
voluntariamente va a ser operado por
ejemplo va a estar bajo anestesia la
última vez que se utilizó fue cuando el
presidente george w.bush iba a tener una
colonoscopia y entonces le pasó los
poderes temporalmente a su
vicepresidente cheney